E aí
[Música]
se você já imaginou ser considerado
incapaz de produzir qualquer coisa
Ah pois é para gente tentar chegar a uma
resposta para essa pergunta queria que a
gente voltasse no tempo e analisar se a
onda da primeira revolução industrial
uma história disse que a Revolução
Industrial foi desencadeada por causas
materiais de investimento roubos altas
taxas de poupanças ou até mesmo do
imperialismo
É mas esse na verdade a primeira
revolução industrial foi desencadeada
devido a uma mudança na mentalidade das
pessoas ou melhor na forma como uma
pessoa lhe dava com a outra
e de acordo com o historiador Econômica
deve Max uma mudança na forma como as
pessoas vão ravam a Inovação possa ter
sido um dos motivos da primeira
revolução industrial surge um conceito
que mudou para melhor o nosso mundo as
pessoas passarão acolher a destruição
criativa ou melhor a produção criativa e
o que é isso nada mais do que a ideia
nova que substitui a antiga faz um
negócio substituir por substituir é uma
substituição que gera valor para vida
das pessoas exemplos clássicos como a
lâmpada elétrica Que destruiu a lâmpada
de querosene os computadores que
destruíram as máquinas de escrever e
tudo isso para quê para o nosso
benefício e para o nosso bem está
Ah e por quê que você conceito ele é
Tecnicamente novo ou na Idade Média
apenas duas classes eram dignas de honra
mas principalmente de grande voz a
nobreza eo clero os plebeus ou outros
que estavam ali comercializando tirando
leite da vaca para fim de troca e
sobrevivência eram inclusive tratados
como pecadores
a atec por volta de 1517 a 1789 uma
mudança mudou completamente o fluxo da
nossa sociedade
e a liberdade a voz EA dignidade
chegaram até as pessoas comuns pela
primeira vez na história da humanidade
e a classe média passou a ser vista mas
muito mais do que Vista ela passou a ser
disputada e autorizado a criar e
produzir e foi a partir do século 18 que
o mundo começou haver mudanças foi a
partir do século 18 que a liberdade a
dignidade chegaram até a classe média
pela primeira vez na história da
humanidade e qual que foi o resultado
disso
I say
o e Atualmente as sociedades que
aderiram à Liberdade à dignidade e
acolheram essa destruição criativa
produzem consomem cerca de cem dólares
por dia lá em 1800 eram três dólares por
dias baseado na mesma tabela de preço
Oi e o padrão se repete em diferentes
escalas se formos falar sobre
organizações ao invés de sociedades por
exemplo as organizações que mais
procuram prosperam são definitivamente
as que dão mais liberdade para os seus
colaboradores Inovar em empresas com
altos graus de Liberdade São no mínimo
10 vezes mais propensas alcançar
melhores desempenhos financeiros
é tão por fim a gente consegue chegar a
uma equação a liberdade
e gera prosperidade através da
produtividade
o quê para provar evidenciar tudo isso
que eu tô aqui falando eu queria trazer
alguns gráficos para a gente analisar o
primeiro gráfico é do Index Of economic
Freedom se analisa o nível de liberdade
econômica das Nações verso nível de
inovação com a linha de tendência na
ascendente diagonal a gente consegue
concluir que ponto maior Liberdade
Econômica automaticamente maior a
Inovação naquele país a mas a Inovação
ela não necessariamente traz melhores no
na vida das pessoas melhorias na vida
das pessoas ou no padrão certo errado
nesse próximo gráfico aqui que eu trouxe
a gente consegue analisar também pelo
menos essa conta é muito fina a
liberdade econômica e o padrão de vida
das pessoas e também na linhas também na
diagonal ascendente a gente consegue
concluir que conta o maior Liberdade
Econômica maior o padrão de vida e pra
finalizar essas análise de gráfico
a nossa aqui o último gráfico que
analisa o grupo dos grupos de países e
seus pibs per capita que a gente
consegue concluir quanto mais livre é um
grupo maior o seu Pib per capta
E com isso conseguimos concluir na
verdade que a inovação tecnológica
impulsionou a produtividade e um
indivíduo que consegue utilizar da sua
força criativa e produtiva para
aproveitar tudo que essa transformação
pode trazer na sua vida tem ganho jamais
vistos
bom e como que a gente consegue trazer
isso para as nossas vidas
o primeiro passo
e a produção é o ato de geração de valor
então precisamos entender que a
produtividade é uma virtude dos e move
isso de nossa segunda eu acho
nós precisamos abraçar a nossa
racionalidade EA Nossa produtividade
o que nos leva ao terceiro baixo
nós precisamos aceitar que somos
responsáveis por sustentar definir
direcionar as nossas próprias vidas e
tudo isso só é possível se formos
indivíduos livres
e tem a liberdade será que seria
possível hoje 45 porcento dos cargos de
liderança será ocupada por nós mulheres
e tem a liberdade será que seria
possível lá no século 18 mel e os
Tomcraft que escreveu uma obra em defesa
dos direitos das mulheres e base ou sua
época sua obra naquela época na
capacidade intelectual e produtiva de
uma mulher
e tem a liberdade será que seria
possível Harry e Taylor escrever sobre o
direito da mulher ter voz o direito dela
decide que seu devido lugar é o maior e
mais alto lugar que nós para nossa
capacidade intelectual somos capazes de
alcançar
Ah pois é na verdade sim a liberdade nem
estaria aqui falando com vocês né
e a liberdade é o caminho e a solução
para os grandes problemas hoje
E para finalizar eu pergunto então a
gente passar a confiar na capacidade do
indivíduo de ser um ser livre racional e
produtivo melhor que tal a gente passar
acreditar e confiar na nossa própria
capacidade
bom obrigada